Ja, das ist mein Name. Ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistenz, als Tätig. Ich würde gerne diese Aufnahmegescheppe mit Ihnen führen.
Falls irgendetwas unklar ist, fragen Sie gerne nach.
Bevor wir Ihre aktuelle Beschwerde kommen, soll ich ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Person stellen. Sind Sie damit ein Verständnis?
Ja, natürlich. Sie müssen ja wissen, mit dem Sie das zu tun haben.
Wie heißt du Sie denn?
Ich heiße Tim Schröder.
Entschuldige, ich habe nicht gut gehört. Die Akustik nicht gut.
Tim Schröder.
Herr Schröder.
Herr Schröder, können Sie bitte Ihre Nachname bestabieren?
Herr SR, R-O-Umlaut, D-E-R.
Schröder, ja?
Herr Schröder.
Wie alt sind Sie, Herr Schröder?
Ich bin 59.
59.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 12. März, 66.
66.
Wie groß sind Sie, Herr Schröder?
81.
80.
Wie viele Wegen Sie aktuelle wissen Sie?
Ja, ich wiege so 70 Kilo.
70 Kilo.
Was führt Sie zu uns? Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen, Herr Schröder?
Ach, wissen Sie, ich habe irgendwie so Probleme mit meinem Bauch, mit meinem...
Ich habe immer Bauchschmerzen und mit der Verdauung habe ich Probleme.
Und in letzter Zeit merke ich, dass es mir so insgesamt auch irgendwie gar nicht gut geht.
Ich habe zum Beispiel, also selbst wenn ich sitze, habe ich das Gefühl, dass ich nicht genug Luft bekomme, ja.
Und zwischendurch schwitzt sich wie verrückt, ja.
Und ich schlafe ganz schlecht ein.
Was?
Ich schlafe schlecht.
Ich schlafe schlecht ein, bin nachts so unruhig, wenn ich mich hinlege.
Und habe überhaupt keinen Appetit, bis Essen schmeckt mir gar nicht.
Und ich habe auch tatsächlich in den letzten Wochen 3 Kilo abgenommen.
Okay.
Aber das Schlimmste sind eben diese Bauchschmerzen und diese wirklich.
Also die werden immer schlimmer auch mit der Zeit.
Okay.
Herr Schröder, Sie haben Bauchschmerzen. Seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerden ungefähr?
Also schon mehrere Wochen. Also ich würde dann über einen Monat auf alle Fälle.
Da vielleicht so fünf Wochen oder so.
Und letzter Zeit Schlimma geworden.
Und das ist, ja, die Schmerzen sind mehr geworden, ja.
Sie haben gesagt, Sie haben ungefähr 3 Kilo abgenommen.
Schmeckt mir gar nicht so.
Welche Zeitraum haben Sie abgenommen?
Ja, so mit dieser Zeit ungefähr. Ja, ja, so seit das angefangen hat.
Ungefähr ein Monat.
Ja, ein bisschen länger, ja, so fünf, sechs Wochen, ja.
Auch Sie haben gesagt, wenn Sie sitzen, haben Sie die Luftnot.
Verstehe ich gut oder richtig oder noch nicht?
Das haben Sie richtig verstanden. Ja, ja, also wie gesagt auch in Ruhe.
Sonst, man kennt das ja, wenn man schnell gelaufen ist,
ja, dass man mal ein bisschen schlecht Luft bekommt.
Oder wenn man 3 Treppen hoch gelaufen ist.
Aber jetzt ist es so, dass, ja, so schon, schon, wenn ich so einfach am Tisch sitze
oder wenn ich was lese oder was arbeite, am Schreibtisch,
dass ich dann einmal merke, puh. Ja, Herr Schröder, wo genau sind die Schmerzen lokalisiert?
Im Bauch, welcher Bauchraum? Oberbauch, Unterbauch oder?
Also eigentlich würde ich sagen, so genau in der Mitte vom Bauch.
Also um den Bauchnabel herum.
Unten Bauchnabel.
Und es, also, das so richtige Krämpfe, der krampft sich alles zusammen
und dann wird es wieder ein bisschen besser.
Und ganz schlimm ist es, wenn dich auf die Toilette muss, ja.
Da sind die Schmerzen ganz heftig, ja.
Sie haben schmerzhafte Stuhlgang.
Ja, das tut, also dann tut das im Bauch richtig doll weh, ja.
Ja, Herr Schröder, wie stark sind Ihre Schmerzen auf einer Skala von 1 bis 10?
1 bedeutet gar kein Schmerzen, 10 bedeutet unverdägliche starke Schmerzen.
Unerträglich ist es natürlich nicht, was soll ich sagen, also über die Hälfte ist es bestimmt.
Also sagen wir mal, ja, 6.
Also nicht nur Mittel, es ist schon ein bisschen mehr als Mittel.
Also ich muss mich schon oft der zusammennehmen, ja.
Ja, ne, so.
Sind die Schmerzen immer da, dauerhaft oder kommt und geht ab und zu?
Also eigentlich sind sie fast immer da, aber besonders stark sind sie eben in so Wellen, ja.
Dass sich das Gehühle, das Krampft sich zusammen und dann ist es besonders stark.
Aber dass ich jetzt so ganz schmerzfrei bin, habe ich die letzten Wochen gar nicht gehabt.
Ja.
Gibt es etwas, dass die Schmerzen lindert oder fast stark, haben Sie etwas bemerkt?
Weil wie gesagt, also wenn ich auf die Toilette gehe, wenn ich Stuhlgang habe, dann ist es ganz unangenehm.
Und ja, was macht es besser?
Also ich habe immer das Gefühl, dass ich dann irgendwann auch ein bisschen aus Erschöpfung einschlage,
wenn ich im Bett liege, ja.
Wenn ich da dann irgendwann die richtige Position gefunden habe, dann ist es eher schrecklich, sagen wir mal.
Ja, ich feste, dass die Schmerzen in der Welt an der Körper verteilen oder nicht immer unter Bauch sitzen.
Also ich würde nicht sagen, dass die im Bauch ausstrahlen.
Das ist jetzt nicht so, dass ich das Gefühl habe, es geht bis in die Schulter oder irgendwo bis in die Beine rein.
Das ist so im Bauchraum.
Haben Sie neben diesen Schmerzen Übelkeit oder Erbrechen?
Also Übel ist mir insofern, dass ich überhaupt keinen Appetit habe.
Das ist mich eigentlich so essen ziemlich anbiedert.
Aber Erbrochen habe ich mich tatsächlich noch nicht.
Aber ich meine, ich habe ohnehin so ein bisschen Probleme schon seit Jahren mit so einer Reflex-Krankheit.
Da nehme ich Umebrazol, damit ich nicht immer dieses saure Aufstoßen habe.
Und ich schlafe auch mit ein bisschen erhöhtem Kopfteilen,
damit ich nicht nachts dieses Gefühl habe, dass mir das so hochläuft.
Verstehe, haben Sie Fieber oder Schutelfrost bemerkt?
Nee, also Fieber, ich habe mich jetzt nicht gemessen.
Schutelfrost habe ich nicht oder hatte ich nicht.
Aber eben diese komischen Schweißausbrüche, das fand ich komisch.
Schweißausbrüche?
Haben Sie nach Schweiß auch?
Nein, das ist gar nicht mal so.
Aber zwischendurch immer ganz überraschend eigentlich.
Frau Schröder, Sie haben während der Stuhlgangschmerzen,
wie ist Ihre Stuhlgang, normale oder Durchfall oder Verstockung?
Frau, das ist großes Durcheinander.
Wissen Sie, mal habe ich das Gefühl, ich kann zwei Tage überhaupt nicht auf die Toilette.
Und dann habe ich wieder so Durchfall,
dass ich dreimal am Tag laufen muss und das ist mir so davonfließt.
Abwechselnder Durchfall und Verstockung?
Das kann man so sagen, ja.
Okay, haben Sie Wasser-Messer-Probleme?
Probleme mit Wasserlassen habe ich eigentlich nicht.
Gut, das freut mich.
Haben Sie Herzstraßen, Herzstolpern oder andere Herzprobleme bemerkt?
Nein, also das ist mir nicht so aufgefallen.
Ich habe das Gefühl, ich bekomme nicht genug Luft.
Sie leiden nur unter Luftnot.
Aber ich habe nicht das Gefühl, dass das Herz dann wieder klopft.
Gut, gut.
Frau Entschuldige, Herr Schröder.
Ich würde gerne ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Krankengeschichte stellen.
Sie haben gesagt, Sie haben Reflexkrankheit und nehmen Sie dagegen Omeprosol?
Ja, gut. Seit wann haben Sie Reflexkrankheit?
Ach, das fing so vor fünf Jahren an, ja.
Erinnern Sie sich daran Omeprosol-Dosierung?
Oh nein, das kann ich Ihnen nicht sagen.
Sie sind zu Hause auf dem Tisch, ich kann Ihnen jetzt nicht sagen,
dass Sie da die Masse haben.
Leiden Sie andere chronische Erkrankungen?
Ja, ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck habe ich, das hat man auch vor zehn Jahren festgestellt.
Und dann nehme ich morgens eine Tablette Walzatran.
Walzatran?
Erinnern Sie sich daran, dass Sie die Dosierung für Medikamente haben?
Ja, das kann ich Ihnen jetzt auch nicht sagen.
Wie gesagt, es liegt alles, die Medikamente liegen bei mir zu Hause neben dem Frühstückstisch.
Haben Sie nicht Medikamentenliste dabei?
Nein, habe ich jetzt nicht mitnehmen.
Okay.
Noch andere Erkrankungen? Leiden Sie?
Ja, also, wo ich jetzt schon seit Jahren ein bisschen Probleme habe,
ich habe einen Hemorrhidenleiden, ja,
und da sind schon mehrfach Bandligaturen gemacht worden.
Und zuletzt war das vor gar nicht langer Zeit, vor zwei Monaten.
Sie leiden an Hemorrhide und Bandligation?
Da sind Bandligationen gemacht worden, genau.
Wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Also außer diesen kleinen Eingriffen da mit den Hemorrhiden,
habe ich sonst keine Operation hinter mir.
Gut, das freut ich auch nicht.
Sie haben gesagt, Sie nehmen Omapresol und Walzatran,
aber nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf noch andere Medikamente?
Ja, also wenn ich mal Schmerzen habe, dann nehme ich Ibuprofen.
Also ich habe zum Beispiel ein bisschen Probleme mit den Knien.
Ja, wenn ich jetzt viel gelaufen bin oder so,
dann tun mir die Knien weh und bevor ich mich um ärger,
nehme ich eine Tablette Ibuprofen und dann geht es einfach wieder.
Haben Sie eine Diagnose für Knieschmerzen?
Nein, so wichtig war mir das bisher noch nicht.
Ich bin da noch nicht mit beim Autopäden.
Frau Entschuldige, Herr Schlüter, ich möchte wieder aktuelle Beschwerde kommen.
Nehmen Sie eine Medikamente dagegen Ihre Bauchschmerzen?
Nein, ich habe mich gar nicht getraut,
weil natürlich habe ich mal ein bisschen Kamelntee getrunken und mal schwarzen Tee.
Das hat alles nicht geholfen.
Und dann habe ich mal so ganz leichtes Essen gegessen,
mal nur Tee und Zwieback und was weiß ich, mal Pudding mir gekocht.
Aber eigentlich ist es, dass ich jetzt Medikamente genommen habe.
Nein, warme oder kalte Anwendung nicht geholfen.
Ich habe mal probiert tatsächlich mit der Wärmflasche,
aber da fand ich gar nicht so angenehm.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Frau Entschuldige, Herr Schlüter, immer sage Frau Entschuldige, Herr Schlüter.
Bin ja auch ein Frau, ja.
Bin bei Ihnen eine Allergie oder Unverträglichkeit bekannt?
Ja, da gibt es etwas, ich darf kein Parazitamol nehmen.
Da kriege ich so einen juckenden Ausschlag davon.
Ausschlag.
Noch andere Unverträglichkeit oder Allergie?
Sonst bin ich eigentlich robust, kann ich alles vertragen.
Könnten Sie mir bitte sagen, ob Sie rauchen?
Ja, also ich rauche schon relativ viel.
Ich rauche zwei Päckchen am Tag, rauche ich schon, ja.
Ein Paket?
Zwei Päckchen am Tag, ja.
Zwei Paket, Entschuldige, zwei Paket, ja.
Seit wann haben Sie Rauchen?
Seit wann ich rauchte?
Ja, da war mal so eine stressige Phase in der Schule,
dann habe ich damit angefangen, das finde ich so vor 15 Jahren,
also vorher habe ich mal sporadisch geraucht,
ja jetzt in den letzten 15 Jahren rauchte es so viel, ja.
10 Jahre.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, so.
Ein bis zwei Gläser Wein gönne ich mehr am Abend, wenn so ein Feierabend einkehrt, ja.
Nein, ja. Bitte nehmen Sie die nächste Frage nicht persönlich,
das ist eine Routinefrage.
Haben Sie Erfahrung mit Drogen?
Ich selber nicht, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Ich bin allerdings Lehrer an einer Schule und da hat man zwangsläufig
ein bisschen Kontakt mit dem Thema,
aber ich selber habe nie irgendwie Drogen genommen.
Ja.
Herr Schrüler, könnten Sie mir bitte sagen, ob Ihre Eltern noch leben?
Also, die sind beide natürlich schon sehr, sehr alt, ja.
Aber die leben beide noch, ja.
Ja, gut. Leiden Sie an chronische Erkrankungen?
Eigentlich sind die erstaunlich fit für Ihr Alter.
Ich weiß nur, dass man bei meinem Vater mal im Rahmen von so einer
Routineuntersuchung Polypen im Darm festgestellt hat.
Aber denke mal, das war nichts Aufregendes.
Polypen, ja.
Mutter bei der Mutter?
Meine Mutter, also, ja, die ist natürlich schon alt und ein bisschen
hinfällig, aber letztendlich so richtig eine erkennbare Krankheit hat sie nicht.
Gut, das freut mich.
Haben Sie Geschwester?
Nein, ich war ein sehr kind.
Ein sehr kind, gut.
Was machen Sie beruflich, Herr Schrüder?
Ich bin Lehrer.
Lehrer.
An einer Gesamtschule.
Ja, gut. Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, wir haben zwei Kinder, aber die sind natürlich schon
erwachsen und aus dem Haus.
Sind Sie gesund?
Ja, klar.
Hoffe ich doch sehr, ja, ja, nee, die sind gesund.
Perfekt, das freut mich.
Haben Sie viel Stress bei der Arbeit oder im Privatleben?
Im Privatleben eher nicht, aber bei der Arbeit hat man logischerweise Stress.
Schule ist heutzutage kein Vermögen, ja.
Herr Schrüder, ich habe alle wichtige Fragen für mich gestellt.
Möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen oder haben Sie Fragen?
Wie geht es jetzt weiter?
Was machen wir gegen die Geschichte und was meinen Sie,
was steckt dahinter, ja?
Ja, wir haben nur eine Anamnese erhoben.
Für eine genaue Diagnose brauchen wir körperliche Untersuchungen,
Laboruntersuchungen und vielleicht Bildgebinde untersuchen.
Sie müssen oder Sie sollen weiter untersuchen
und Behandlung bei uns ein paar Stunden bleiben.
Nach dem Unterversuchung sind abgeschlossen,
können wir die genaue Ihre Bescheide wieder schiprieren.
Okay, das klingt gut, ja.
Danke schön.
Haben Kollegen oder Kollegen noch andere Fragen?
Ich habe zwei Fragen.
Ja, bitte.
Haben Sie in der letzten Seite lauter Darngeräusch und Stullformveränderung,
z.B. Dünastull bemerkt?
Habe ich ja gesagt.
Ich habe gesagt, ich habe im Wettsel heftige Durchfälle und Verstopfungen.
Ja, und bei Durchfällen hat man natürlich auch heftige Darmgeräusche, ja.
Okay.
Und Sie haben gesagt, Sie haben Hemorrhoid und dagegen Operation durchgeführt.
Haben Sie damals Darmspiegelung?
Die letzte ist schon fast zehn Jahre her.
Zehn Jahre, okay. Danke schön.
Also vielleicht habe ich gesagt, aber ich habe nicht mitbekommen.
Leiden Sie unter Stuhldrang?
Unter noch was?
Stuhldrang, also müssen Sie sich flüssig aufs Klo gehen?
Also das wechselt von Tag zu Tag, ja.
Manche Tage muss ich sehr häufig auf die Toilette gehen
und habe Durchfall, flüssige Stühle
und manche Tage kann ich überhaupt nicht auf die Toilette gehen.
Bin ich verstopft und dann ist der Stuhl ganz fest.
Keine Stuhldrang, keine Inkontinenz.
Ach, das meinst du?
Ja, ja, ja.
Inkontinenz, Stuhlinkontinenz, nein.
So schlimm ist es nicht.
Also meistens schaffe ich es noch bis zur Toilette, ja.
Ja, also ich wollte wissen, ob Sie Tennismus haben.
Heißt das Tennismus oder?
Ich kann Sie ganz schlecht verstehen.
Bei der Stuhlfühle ist eine schmerzhafte Stuhlgang.
Stuhlgang.
Das heißt.
Ah, okay.
Keine.
Ernste Beschwerden gefragt, oder?
Nein, er hat ja tatsächlich nicht gefragt, ob ich früher schon mal so etwas hatte,
aber hatte ich nicht.
Sind Sie schon einmal einen anderen Arzt gewesen?
Nein, ich war auch nicht bei meinem Hausarzt weiter, damit ich nicht.
Alkoholkonsum.
Sie haben genau Erklären ein bisschen.
Sie haben gesagt, jeden Tag trinken Sie.
Und deswegen am Wochenende und so weiter könnten Sie bitte...
Also, er trinkt jeden Abend Glas Wein.
Wenn es etwas zu feiern gibt, trinkt er auch mal mehr, ja, natürlich.
Wir leben in Deutschland, ja.
Da wird hier das Ruhm.
Im Stadion hat er auch nicht gefragt.
Herr Schroederhausli ist schon blässig in der Haut bemerkt?
Na ja, es ist Winter, da sieht man eh nicht so gut aus.
Da ist man immer ein bisschen blass, ja.
Aber, ja, also meine Frau sagt immer, du siehst krank aus, ja, zur Zeit.
Okay, danke.
Die hat mich auch hierher geschickt.
Herr Schroeder, hat sich die Farbe ihres Schutuls verändert?
Blutig, Schwarz oder Tier-Schwarz?
Nein, Schwarz ist das nicht.
Natürlich, das kenne ich ja von den Hämorrhiden, dass da so ein bisschen Blut mit dabei ist.
Aber das war jetzt in letzter Zeit eigentlich nicht.
Okay, danke.
Sie haben gesagt, Appetitlosigkeit.
Appetitlosigkeit, ja.
Trinken Sie Wasser genug, jeden Tag?
Eigentlich bemühe ich mich genug zu trinken, ja.
Bei der Arbeit immer eine Flasche Wasser stehen in der Schule für die Pausen.
Und auch zu Hause am Schreibtisch steht immer eine Karaffe mit Wasser.
Und ich trinke, also auch viel Tee, also eigentlich trinke ich genug, den würde ich sagen, ja.
Ich denke, alle Fragen gestellt.
Frau Oberstein, könnte wir das an den...
Von mir aus können wir loslegen, immer.
Und dann, Dr. Scheide, wie weit er ist mit dem Bericht.
Fangen wir an, Schade?
Ja, ja. Ich habe so, so viele Zeit.
Ich brauche.
Guten Abend, Frau Oberarztin.
Ich habe heute neue Patienten aufgenommen.
Ich möchte Ihnen sie vorstellen, haben Sie Zeit?
Ja, aber Sie möchten ihn vorstellen.
Entschuldige, ihn vor, ja.
Ihnen immer sagt, Frau.
Herr Tim Schröder ist ein 59-jähriger Patient, zeitlich, örtlich und persönlich orientiert
und normal gewichtigen Ernährungszustand und beschwerde bedingte, deutlich reduziertem Allgemeinszustand.
Der Patient stellte sich heute auf unserer Station mit einer seit fünf Wochen bestehenden,
progredienten, krampfartige Wellenförmige Abdominalgie ohne Schütterung vor,
die von...
Ausstrahlung?
Ohne Schütterung und die von... Entschuldige, im Periumplikalregio.
Periumplikalregio ohne Schütterung und vor, die von Dispne und Gewichtverlust,
ungefährlich, ungefährlich 3 Kilo innerhalb von fünf Wochen begleitet sein.
Darüber hinaus leider er unter Tennismus, heftige Tarkeschmerzen beim Sturrgang.
Ja.
Okay.
Dr. Scheide, ich muss Sie mal eben kurz unterbringen.
Versuchen Sie mal, nicht nach jedem zweiten Wort zu machen.
Das ist extrem aufwählig.
Versuchen Sie mal bewusst, das wegzulassen, ja?
Okay.
Nach Aussage der Patient, der Patient hat Dispne bei der Belastung und auch in der Ruhe,
die Intensität der Bauchschmerzen wurde sechs von zehn auf einer numerischen Skala angegeben.
Auf der Patient klagt über Übelkeit und Abwechslung der Diare und Konstipation.
Mhm.
Auch Erleide unter Fatikö, Erschöpfatikö, ja?
Fatikö, mhm.
Fatikö, Fatikö.
Die vegetative Anamnese, bis auf oben genannte Symptome und Appetitlosigkeit und beschwerde
Bedingte ins Omni bis unauffällig.
Mhm.
Und Anvor Erkrankungen, leider er seit fünf Jahren Reflexkrankheit.
Erleide an einer Reflexkrankheit, ja?
Erleide an Reflexkrankheit, seit fünf Jahren Reflexkrankheit und die Medikamentös-Omeplose
behandelt worden sei.
Mhm.
Außer dem, leider er seit zehn Jahren Arteriale-Hypertonie, die mit Walzatran
eingestellt worden sei.
Mhm.
Erleide an Hemorrhoid und letzte Zeit zwei Mal Bandligation durchgeführt werden.
Ja.
Durchgeführt wurde, durchgeführt wurde.
Es wurde zweimal eine Bandligatur durchgeführt, okay?
Mhm.
Im Bezug auf Medikation, Medikation nehme er oben genannte Medikamente und Ibuprofen
dagegen Knieschmerzen ein.
Also Ibuprofen nimmt er zusätzlich ein, noch zu den anderen Sachen, weil er manchmal
durchgeführt wird.
Ja, okay.
Mhm.
Okay.
Auf die Frage nach Allergien und Unverträglichkeiten gab der Patient an, Paracetamol,
Entschuldige, gab der Patient an, auf Paracetamol mit Exantem zu reagieren.
Mhm.
Okay.
Ich muss noch Familien an einem Nese-Sozial haben.
Ja, aber ich, um auf die Frage nach Noxun, gab der Patient an, seit 15 Jahre raucher
zu sein und erraucher ungefähr zwei Packung, zwei Packung täglich, das heißt,
oder das bedeutet 30 Packers.
Sehr gut.
Mhm.
Er trink ein oder zwei Glas Wein abend, Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
Anfamilien, Anamnese gab der Patient an, Polyposis, an Polyposis bei der Vater,
bei dem Vater und Mutter hat keine auffälligen Probleme.
Aber beide leben noch.
Ja.
Beide Eltern leben noch.
Beide Eltern leben noch, ja.
Mhm.
Ja, Alter, ja.
Herr Schruder ist Lehrer und verheiratet, hat zwei gesunde Kinder.
Er habe viel Stress bei der Arbeit.
Da kann man sich vorstellen, ja.
Die anamnestischen Angaben deuten am ehesten auf eine chronische Darmenzündung hin.
Dafür spricht vor allem Abwechslender, Diare und Konstipation, Gewichtverlust und
Bauchschmerzen und Tänismus.
Ja, die außerdem unterstütze die Risikofaktoren, so wie Rauchen und Stress,
meine Verdachtsdiagnose.
Ja, wirst du das differentialdiagnostisch noch sein?
Ja, als Differentialdiagnose kommen die Folgen der Erkrankungen in Betrat,
Ulceratives Colitis und Morbus Crohn oder Magenentsündung, ja, Ulcus Ventriculi,
vielleicht.
Was fehlt uns noch, ja, Differentialdiagnose?
Als Differentialdiagnose.
Ach gut, nicht Achut Pankratit, was wir sagen, vielleicht, ja, ich erinnere nicht mehr.
Gucken Sie mal, B-Symptomatik.
Oh, Diverticulitis, ja, Dr. Pupil hat geschrieben, Diverticulitis auch.
Ja, und was noch?
Diverticulitis.
Denken Sie doch mal an die B-Symptomatik, er hat Gewicht verloren, er hat Nachtspartig.
Okay, Parginom, Darm-Kardinom.
Ja, Kolonkarsinom, genau.
Kolonkarsinom, Kolonkarsinom.
Ja, was machen Sie mit dem Patientendiagnostisch?
Ja, zuerst sollen wir körperliche Untersuchung durchführen, eine körperliche Untersuchung.
Woaus achten Sie bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Ja, ich achte darauf, die Bauchschmerzen und Strahlen und Abwehrspannung oder Brustschmerzen oder Loslassschmerzen.
Ich überprüfe die Bauch.
Den Bauch?
Den Bauch, den Bauch.
Was machen Sie mit Ihren Augen?
Bei der Inspektion überprüfe ich die Dispno-Probleme.
Ah, ja, okay.
Und was noch?
Ihre Körperposition vielleicht?
Vielleicht auch, ja, aber Sie haben vorhin mal oder wurde gefragt, ob ich besonders blass bin.
Oh, ja, blass, Ihre Hautfarbeveränderungen, blass oder nicht?
Ja, beziehungsweise, ne?
Anämien, ja, ja, ja.
Augen für Anämie.
Ja, genau.
Gut, ja.
Und was machen Sie diagnostisch noch weiter, außer der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Ja, nach dem körperlichen Untersuchung soll ich Labor-Untersuchung durchführen.
Deswegen nehme ich Blut ab und Blutbild, um die Anämie auszuschließen
und Einzündung, Parameter auch.
Lieberwerte, Nierenwerte und Elektrolytwerte.
Was machen Sie mit Labor-Untersuchung noch?
Stuhlprobe und Blut, occult Blut insbesondere.
Hemokul-Test, ne? Genau, sehr gut.
Gut, wie geht es weiter?
Welche Untersuchung machen Sie noch?
Sollen wir zuerst Ultrasonographie im Bauch Ultrasonographie?
Dann, vielleicht gegebenenfalls brauchen wir Bauch CT,
aber insbesondere Endoskopie und Kolonoskopie,
die richtigen Bildgebinde verfahren.
Genau.
Für diese Fall.
Endoskopie und Kolonoskopie spielen eine sehr wichtige Rolle für diese Fallendiagnose.
Ich habe den Anfang nicht mitbekommen.
Was spielt das?
Endoskopie und Kolonoskopie.
Natürlich, ja, ja.
Sie spielen die richtige Rolle.
Gut, dann bin ich gespannt, was Sie rausfinden bei Herrn Schröder.
Halten Sie mich über die Untersuchungen auf dem laufenden
und dann gucken wir uns den Patienten nachher nochmal zusammen ab.
Gut.
Also, kann ich sagen Therapie?
Ach so, Therapie.
Wir wissen ja auch nicht, was rauskommt.
Wir können dann zu welchem Fall, welche Therapie.
Was weiß ich, wenn wir jetzt sagen,
er hat eine Darmentzündung oder ein Reizdarm,
eine Verkaufsprung.
Was wären dann die Therapieoptionen?
Ja, zuerst sollen wir die Patienten über die Behandlungsmöglichkeiten
und Risikofaktoren informieren.
Dann sollen wir die Medikamentöse,
zuerst medikamentöse Therapie und präventive Massnahme empfehlen.
Nekotinkarren, Alkoholkarrens und Stress zu reduzieren
und entspannende Techniken mehr...
Ausreichender Flüssigkeit und ausreichende und ausgegoge Nährung
ist selbst so.
Und regelmäßig und ausreichende Schlafen ist gut,
um die Stress zu reduzieren und auch medikamentös Therapie.
Gut, und für den Fall, dass ich tatsächlich rausdelt,
dass der ein Karzinom hat?
Operative Behandlung, ja.
Ja, wie auch immer.
Teilentfernung oder...
Es kann möglich sein.
Ja, genau.
Gut, ja, wie gesagt, dann schauen wir mal,
was tatsächlich ist mit den Patienten
und wie gesagt, wir sprechen nachher noch über ihn, ja?
Gut, alles klar.
Okay.
Ja, inhaltlich kann ich ganz, ganz wenig meckern.
Sprachlich habe ich in Haufen Probleme.
Sprachlich habe ich eine Menge Probleme.
Sie haben das sehr souverän gemacht.
Ich habe sie ja gleich am Anfang, habe ich sie ein bisschen geblockt,
als sie angefangen haben zu sprechen und habe gesagt,
machen Sie den nicht ständig das Eh.
Das war wirklich extrem,
dass sie es fast vor jedem Wort gemacht haben.
Und ich weiß, dass ein des Totales aus der Bahn wirft,
wenn man darauf jetzt mit einmal achten soll,
dann ist der Faden abgeschnitten, ja?
Dann heißt man überhaupt nicht mehr,
dass man sich nicht mehr auf das Thema, was man sagen soll.
Und man muss richtig kämpfen mit der Formulierung.
Nur es war wirklich sehr, sehr signifikant,
dass Sie das permanent gebracht haben.
Beim Fragestellte Bereich nicht, also nicht so stark,
aber beim Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch war es mir wirklich zu massiv.
Deswegen habe ich gleich gesagt,
versuchen Sie mal darauf zu verzichten.
Dann ist mir aufgefallen,
dass man sie nicht so gut versteht,
weil sie praktisch keine Satzmelodie machen.
Sie machen die Sätze praktisch in einem Stück
und sie sprechen gar nicht falsch aus,
aber sie sagen zum Beispiel,
der Patient beschreibt Luftnot in Ruhe und bei Belastung.
Also sie machen alles auf einer Sprachhöhe
und sie trauen diesen Bogen, damit wir wissen so,
an dieser Stelle ist der Satz zu Ende.
Und jetzt fängt ein neuer Satz an.
Sonst verlieren wir den Faden, wo ist er denn gerade?
Auch wenn sie Worte richtig aussprechen,
sagen wir gegen die Atelierle hypertonie,
nimmt er Walzartat ein.
Wenn sie das alles richtig aussprechen,
aber sie haben diese Sprachmelodie nicht,
haben wir wirklich große Nöte, sie gut zu verstehen.
Aber ich muss Probleme.
Ja, ich weiß nicht,
versuchen Sie mal das ein bisschen zu üben.
Man kann das ganz gut üben, wenn man liest.
Wenn man einen Text vorliest,
einen vorgedruckten deutschen Text vorliest,
dann kann man es üben.
Und wenn jemand zuhört und sagt,
hallo, hallo, da musst du aufpassen,
dann ist es noch besser.
Gut, das ist diese Geschichte.
Eine sprachliche Besonderheit ist eine Winzigkeit.
Ich mach das selber auch.
Ich weiß es genau.
Wir machen es alle, aber nicht so oft wie Sie.
Sie haben beim Gesicht Gewichtsverlust,
haben sie angegeben,
er hat ungefährlich 3 kg abgenommen.
Ungefährlich ist etwas, was nicht gefährlich ist,
also von dem keine Gefahr aus geht.
Das Wichtige ist ungefähr.
Ungefähr, ja, ungefährlich.
Das ist ein sehr charmanter Fehler.
Bei Beschreibung der Schmerzen haben Sie gesagt,
ohne Strahlung.
Ich habe es einfach vorgestellt,
ohne Ausstrahlung.
Die Schmerzen strahlen nicht woanders hin aus.
Trännbares Verb ausstrahlen.
Wir benutzen immer Strahlen aus.
Ich benutze hier zusammen,
deswegen vergesse ich aus.
Das ist mir auch noch aufgefallen,
dass Sie in Ihren ersten Satz,
Sie haben da echt viel reingepackt.
Aber Sie haben so viel reingepackt,
dass ich der ganzen Geschichte nicht mehr folgen konnte.
Sie entschärfen Sie diesen ersten Satz.
Der Patient stellte sich mit seit 5 Wochen bestehenden,
progrädienten,
powerumpfrikalen Bauchschmerzen vor.
Die Schmerzen sind begleitet von,
die Schmerzen sind nicht mehr so,
dass sie sich nicht mehr auf die Schmerzen vergesstraht haben.
Versuchen Sie nicht,
lauter Nebenbedingungen noch reinzubringen.
Sondern machen Sie da lieber einen neuen Satz.
Sonst wissen Sie am Ende vom Satz nicht mehr,
wie Sie angefangen haben.
Ich habe hier schon sehr oft gesagt,
ich weiß, dass das ein bisschen im Kontrast ist zu dem,
so zu beladen,
da haben Sie nachher gar keine Chance mehr,
noch etwas zu ergänzen.
Es muss nicht alles in einem Satz gesagt werden.
Das war diese Geschichte.
Die Ausdrahlung.
Dann haben Sie sich ein bisschen schwer geteilt,
die Einleitung zu finden für die Familienanamnese.
Da würde ich Ihnen vielleicht empfehlen, zu sagen.
Ich habe so viel Papier,
ich misste die Papier seit.
Ja, aber es geht darum,
dass Sie eben nicht sagen,
Familienanamnese,
der Vater des Patienten leidet an Dampolin,
sondern, dass Sie eben sagen,
zur Familienanamnese gab der Patient an
oder in der Familienanamnese ergab sich,
dass Sie da eine kleine Formulierung
für die ganzen Eingang hatten.
Genau.
Das kann ich mal in der eigene Schrift nicht lesen.
Bei der Schmerzanlage haben Sie auch gesagt,
die Schmerzen wurden 6 von 10 angegeben.
Die Schmerzen,
also die Schmerzintensität,
die Schmerzintensität wurde mit 6 von 10 angegeben.
Auf der Rückseite habe ich nichts bestehen.
Sie machen manchmal eine komische Satzstellung.
Das kann man vernachlässigen,
das ist keine Katastrophe.
Aber das Schwierigste an Ihrer sprachlichen Verständlichkeit
ist diese Ferien-Desats-Melodie.
Das kann man ein bisschen üben.
Aber versuchen Sie das bis zur Prüfung
noch ein bisschen mehr zu modulieren.
Dass man mehr Betonung in den Sätzen hat.
Dann kann man sie deutlich besser verstehen.
Üben Sie es beim Lesen.
Dass Sie sich richtig bewusst sagen,
wo ist der Höhepunkt von meinem Satz?
Zum Ende geht die Stimme wieder runter.
Wenn ich eine Frage habe, können Sie mir dazu etwas sagen.
Bei einer Frage geht am Ende.
Die Betonung nach oben.
Wir haben auch die Möglichkeit,
wenn wir ein Satz formulieren,
dass wir etwas an den Anfang setzen,
das wir besonders wichtig finden.
Wir müssen nicht immer diese strenge Regel einhalten,
das Subjekt, Verb, Objekt,
sondern wir können durchaus auch sagen,
zu den Schmerzen gab der Patient an,
dass sie sich so und so verhalten.
Wir können ruhig etwas an den Anfang setzen,
das uns wichtig ist.
Auf direkte Anfrage erwähnte der Patient
Nachtschweißausbrüche.
Das ist eine sehr gute Frage.
Man darf das schon variieren.
Vergesst nicht,
eine Satzmelodie reinzubringen.
Alte Predigt, Verb,
und dann mache ich.
Das sind relativ einfache
Grammatikregeln.
Das sind die Stimme,
die wir in der Stimme machen.
Das ist schwer,
die im ganzen Chaos,
wo man so viele Sachen beachten will und muss,
das auch noch zu beachten.
Man kann das ruhig hören,
dass sie kein Muttersprachler sind.
Das darf man ruhig hören.
Ungefährlich fand ich sehr schabant.
Es ist wirklich so,
dass man nicht zu viel auf einmal
an Baustellen in der Sprache haben sollte.
Mit der zunehmenden Satzmelodie
haben Sie die schon halbwegs gebrummt.
Das sind meine Tipps für Sie.
Dr. Gündes guckt ein bisschen grimmig.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Der Patient hat gesagt,
Prästymialergie.
Sie können den Ausschlag.
Sie können die jukreis-Priorität
mit diesem Ausschlag exantieren.
Wie können wir das präsentieren?
Das ist bei der Arsatzgespräche.
Die Allergie äußert sich
mit Exantäme und Prüthus.
Das kann man sagen.
Oder gibt der Patient eine Parazitamolallergie
an, die sich mit jukreis- und puritus äußert.
Das ist immer möglich.
Relativsätze sind auch ein sprachlich,
ein relativ elegantes Mittel.
Dass man so ein bisschen
Variation in der Sprache drin hat.
Überhaupt Haupt- und Nebensätze.
Aber das machen wir ja nicht bewusst.
Das machen wir häufig schon unbewusst.
Dass wir eine Begründung angeben.
Nachdem der Patient das gemacht hat,
ist das passiert.
Aber grundsätzlich müssen wir uns
ein bisschen an die Sprache halten.
Dr. Günis, haben Sie sonst noch was
für den Kollegen?
Vielen Dank.